what is the craziest fan request because
your fans are very very intense and it
can get personal what's the craziest fan
request that you've had I have had a lot
of because of who negan is I get a lot
of kind of odd sexual requests because
because negan is such a bad yes I think
they think he's like dominant we know
what you mean he wears leather I mean
it's crazy but I've gotten like like
ball gag gifts whips I had some Heath
you might have to edit this out I had
somebody ask me to use Lucille and make
them a popsicle and I was like baseball
bat thank you and I'm like through
hardwire yeah and by the way I was doing
the math in my head when this request
but I know I was very confused by it I'm
like yeah so that gets very passionate
fans do you say are these are the things
that they ask you face to face or how is
this communicated cuz that would take a
lot of guts to just ask you a lot of the
time because I'll do like a fan events
where you can go and and meet fans and
yeah and you know you sign an autograph
or or take a picture and and they slip
you notes yeah they give you the notes
woman's slipping you a note I get that
mine say mine's day might say you don't
look well
I've gotten that before do ya you get
you seem to have lost a lot of weight
lately are you okay